I want to close off this lesson by
saying a really quick note and then I
need to show you something which will
emphasize why it's important that you
are drawing your graphs really
accurately and why if you have a
template you are actually at an
advantage of the first thing I want to
point out it what if we just established
its estimate engine rules and so on okay
at this stage in the course you know how
to integrate a lot of things a lot of
things like in fact as extension one
students you pretty much know how to
integrate everything you'll ever need to
do in the extension one course that's a
big deal extension to people you're a
little ways to go I mean you have a
whole topic port integration but we have
a whole bunch of these for instance we
know all of these anything that is a
straight polynomial we know how to do we
also know how to integrate a whole bunch
of rational functions the syphilis one
we know is this one what kind of a
function are we gonna get if we get to
write this guy think think carefully is
it the log function right now I'm just
going to for now I'm not going to worry
about the absolute value because all I
try to draw attention to is the fact
that even though what I started with was
something that's just algebraic right
it's just it's if X is there's a
division happening and everything that's
in a similar kind of you know any
polynomial that's combined in this way
will also lend you is a log function
that's kind of surprising right it's a
little bit like yeah i just started with
polynomials and when i put them together
in interesting combinations you end up
getting wrongs and then here we've gone
even further out like what wasn't that
surprising that if you differentiate
sine cos and tan which our trig
functions you get more treat functions
okay sure that's in that one sphere but
now but this is just algebra it's just
algebra and when you integrate it you
end up in the shrinks fear that's kind
of weird okay but also very interested
in surprise
now that's the first thing I just want
to draw attention to the second thing is
I need to make an argument for you for
why your grass the pain feel good and
not it because your graphs should be
really good of their own accord but
there are getting some questions you
cannot answer full stop if your graphs
it a good okay this is all about just
integrating with respect to algebra that
lands you in an inverse trig function
okay however I want you to contemplate
this question with it what if I were to
give you say here here's what you do
office okay now this despite how I built
it from all the same building boxes
we've been dealing with this lesson this
is a whole different beast isn't it like
this is not you start with some algebra
and you end up with an inverse trig
function this is starting with an
inverse trig function it's saying where
are you going to land ok now it's a big
clue to you that this is not just a
definite integral I've got some values
here those values are actually very very
important ok so this is a definite
integral which means what a definite
integrals about like what kind of
problem did we come up with to solve
their area right area under a curve so
this corresponds to a picture can we
draw let's just draw a briefing where I
take you long go ahead put yourself to
the other set of axes and draw your
picture
hmm
people
encouraging
okay now here's my regular unmodified
cos inverse reps right so I should label
it and so now what area is being
referred to here I'm going from negative
a half to a half and I know exactly
where that news so I can say okay it's
gonna be half way that way and half way
this way so now I can actually paint on
what area be represented by this
definite integral ok so I'm going from
negative uh-huh that was little car to a
half this is the shape I've got ok now
this shape here
this shape is weird shape is weird right
how am I going to deal with this now you
have some choices you have some choices
I don't know at the moment it's not in
my toolbox to integrate an inverse trig
function ok so I just can't get an
answer straight out from from all the
stuff that I've seen it's certainly not
the reference [ __ ] okay but I do know
how to integrate regular trig functions
regulatory functions and I know that
this comes from a regular trig function
so here's one trick I could pull and I
won't show you like proper examples of
this later but it's quite involved if I
turn this sideways right and turn it
back into a regular trig function it
could look something like this this is
like a part of the cause ground right
it's a part of the clothes back it's
this part if i draw regular cause and
that domain I go from nought it's a pie
there it is yes that's that's where I
end now where is that on here well here
is one at negative 1 to agree with that
so what I've done is I have to look at
everything sideways so here's a half and
negative on top so I've got the same
kind of boundaries ok and now if you
turn your head sideways here's what I'm
after do you see that and this is still
a bit messy ok but I can do with if i
want to buy saying look if I slice it in
that way what I've got to the left is a
rectangle and what I've got to the right
I can deal with that just with my normal
integration tools I don't have to slice
this up into a positive part and a
negative part but I can do it is my work
this is fine but it's messy it's
involved even without me actually
staying to putting the algebra on the
Boyne you're like our this is gross okay
if your graph is decent there's
something smiler you can do here what
you have a look because it messes funny
because it doesn't have odd or even
symmetry right it doesn't have Orion
surgery however as all three punctures
do you it has a marvelous amount of
symmetry to it and you'll see it if
you're graphing this Headley good do you
get you might quit yet hey watch these
two parts together how do they relate
well I hope you notice that this
distance of this distance I'd say you
notice that those myths are the scene
you have a look see how this plaid
decreases and this part decreases right
look carefully the concavity do you
think these two pieces actually fit
together actually fit together if i draw
upwards here I wonder if your brand is
good enough to be able to see that this
area over here and this area over here
are identical do you see that now if
you're like me i started off my field
for this very well so what I just showed
you I'll color it a little positive what
I just showed you is not obvious at all
because I haven't busted my curvature
yet hey there's an easy way to get the
curvature exactly right every single
time so that this thing is obvious to me
okay if that's the case how am I going
to work out my thoughts on what shape if
I just created there's a rectangle right
it has a width of half a minute
and it has a height of players so this
insoluble problem before turns out to be
marvelously simple if you understand a
junkie and your graph is good enough for
you to take advantage of that and you
might say it bad that's tough well yes
however number one the other way is
tougher and number two it is absolutely
are tended often better soon it'll wake
up it is absolutely possible for you on
paper especially if you're using a
template to be able to take advantage of
that geology let me show you this really
feels the first time I encountered a
question like this yeah there it is okay
the first time I encountered a question
like this my graph literally was not
good enough to be able to see the
cemetery at all it wasn't select record
okay but when you have a look at it you
can say yeah all right if you've got
like I drew this I drew this with a
template because I I wasn't able to draw
it at that stage this is a few years ago
um accurately enough to make that
argument template
we have two so that you get the shapes
ride until such a time as you must start
being able to draw a tree graph that
well and I don't know I'm going to take
you awhile so you're I believe it's a
current member it's like totally
tailored here it's 13 16 or 18 I believe
and the question will say you see a
graph and symmetry evaluate and then
they'll hand you a ton of the board
they'll hand you a definite integral
such as this and there if you have to
draw a graph without my graphic arts say
this right I'm dependent on my graph and
the demonstration of my shifting of
areas to be able to justify that ok any
questions
so um um no not really it's it's such a
table disaster that it's so much fun to
do everything you need to do if you ever
want to integrate anniversary function
you'd do it this way right all you'd
rearrange such that everything is in
terms of regulatory function to use
inverse properties rather than those
brothers